[Music]
let me welcome you to the eighth talk in
this quarterly series so we've been
doing it's now for two years this time
we're talking about Friedrich Nietzsche
and I titled this talk free to nature
the apex of the West and the threat of
Neil ISM so we're going to talk a good
bit about this term
niall ism and Nietzsche's influence on
culture but in each of these talks we
try to take the philosopher whoever he
or she is and situate them in relation
to what was going on at the time what
would form them what they took part in
so you know we looked at Aristotle and
his relationship with Alexander the
Great for example or Louie theus and how
you know Western culture was essentially
falling apart at that time and the power
struggles that we're going on looked at
hominin rent last last year we capped
her as at the end of the series we
looked at the Holocaust in
totalitarianism so this time I wanted to
pick somebody who you know everybody
would have some views on it's like a
very controversial figure Friedrich
Nietzsche I should thank the Frank
Weinberg library and Ashley Pike the
adult services coordinator and also my
wife and partner Ian shaka who's not
here tonight but but you know who likes
these series quite a bit who helps to
set them up but I should also mention
that we've been renewed for another year
worth of talks so they don't have the
bookmarks yet because I've given the
information he actually yet but we're
gonna start with Cicero
in the spring great Latin philosopher a
very interesting guy you'll see why and
then for our medieval thinker around
Maine we'll talk about Augustine of
Hippo the great you know converse you
could say somebody who knew sin inside
and out because he committed many of
them then for the modern period we'll do
John Locke and we'll camp the euro off
by talking about Albert Camus 20th
century thinker so and I should also
mention what other things
provisions before this we do actually
have a free webinar coming up this month
if you're interested in that I can tell
you more about it next week Monday the
13th we're doing a 45 minute webinar on
Nietzsche using our reason IO site and
then we have some more intensive online
seminars to hour-long seminars on
Saturday so if you're if you want more
Nietzsche that that's one way to get it
those are going to be focused mostly on
this early book the birth of tragedy and
some of the things that are going on
from there tonight we're going to talk
about you know sort of the totality
Nietzsche's works so in each of these
talks what I try to do like I said is
situate the philosopher in relation to
his or her own times talk about maybe
some of the contributions they make
because it's kind of a back and forth
process they're formed and shaped by the
issues of their time they think about it
but they also affect it as well so it's
not just a one way street and with
Nietzsche I think we can say there's
there's a lot going on there of this
sort what I'm going to talk about then
is sort of what was going out of the
19th century and some of the culture of
the time some of the developments well
look at Nietzsche's own wife and then
we'll dive into this issue of me ilysm
and we'll talk about how Nietzsche
himself contributed to understanding it
some of his only other ideas that fit in
with his response to it and then we can
talk about Nietzsche's influence at any
point if you've got questions or
comments that you want to make we can we
can stop we can consider them I can
always get us back on track
sort of like a horse that knows the
trail especially with a thinker like
Nietzsche who I've been interested in
since I was a teenager and probably
quite frankly I can say that probably
half of the time that I read an each I
misunderstood him especially when I was
younger
I was taking the wrong ideas from him
but I think that's that's quite common
with me hmm with many other thinkers
Albert Camus of the same services story
started reading him when I was 14 and I
don't think I really understood more
than a tenth of what I was reading
Nietzsche became somebody I was very
interested in when I was in graduate
school as a student working on my
masters and then on my PhD I even went
through what I would call him each a
phase where I thought that he was the
philosopher you know and I used to argue
with some of the other graduate students
about how we ought to interpret
Nietzsche properly how we ought to apply
it and I think like many other people
who get interested in Nietzsche I tried
to figure out what it would be like to
be the Superman the Hoover mesh and that
turns out to be very difficult to do so
what we will talk about that theme but I
ended up moving out of that into other
things but Nietzsche has remained for me
somebody who I think is centrally
important especially for understanding
the 19th century the 20th century where
philosophy is today he's probably you
know if you had to pick top ten
philosophers he's probably going to be
in there for a lot of people so let's
talk about the 19th century very heady
times you know it begins with these
Napoleonic Wars in in Europe Europe is
in a ferment and then apollyon ik wars
were not just this guy who was a general
who actually wasn't quite as short as
they make him out to be that's a bit of
a historical fable but he was definitely
imperialistic and he had a France that
had been finalised by the French
Revolution and turned essentially into a
military machine and he was attempting
to unite Europe into one big system and
then these other European powers are
trying to resist eventually Napoleon
loses it was quite a run that he had but
in a invades Russia loses most of his
army there comes back to raise in
another army in France and by that time
the German states are in rebellion and
in Wars of liberation Britain has been
mixing it up the entire time and F a
Napoleon is gone there's a new
configuration of power in Europe you
know they the powers that are there
become much more conservative they want
to keep this sort of revolutionary
activity from happening and you could
say that revolution was one of the great
themes what's happening in the 19th
century revolutions not just in terms of
political causes and reconfigurations
but also in terms of transformation of
society so we have these these social
conflicts going on you know this is the
century that sees not just Marx and
Engels writing the communist manifesto
but all sorts of socialist and utopian
ideals being being put forward some of
them even here in the States think about
some of what the transcendentalist were
doing there's there's great discussions
you know what do the classes Oh II chose
who are you know making a lot of money
through industrial capitalism do they
owe anything to the mass of the workers
who should be in charge all these things
become contestant some of the countries
within Europe are still being governed
and rather archaic ways by a king or
Nobles some of them become democracies
and you know we know from our own you
know recent elections that democracy can
sometimes be very exciting and but it's
also prone to all sorts of crazy
conflicts now just imagine new
democracies where there isn't any like
200 year tradition like we have of
holding elections and all this sort of
stuff think back to when our when our
early elections were like and how much
crazy stuff went on that's what's
happening across Europe you could say
that politically you've got you know not
only you know sort of progressivism you
know that wants to change society
teaming up against a kind of
conservativism which looks different in
in different places you've also got
these radicals who want to totally
transform society this is an idea that
really took currency in the French
Revolution and continues on
there's also struggles over religion
going on within Europe Europe had seen
several hundred years of religious wars
sometimes very bloody you know it which
at one point cost Germany about half of
its population just two centuries before
that and a lot of those things have been
sort of sorted out by them instead it's
it's a question how do we interpret
traditional religion some people are
calling for to get rid of it altogether
the French Revolution and in fact that
an anti clerical revolution they took
all these monks and nuns and and you
know put them into lay life and there
there were you know a lot of people who
resisted and then we're getting as a
result you know within Pratt within you
might say the entire Protestant spectrum
particularly in Germany there's a lot of
rethinking about how do we adapt
religion traditional Christianity to a
modern age and there's a lot of
controversy and disputes between people
and actually the notion of meal ISM is
going to emerge originally from those
those two things nationalism is becoming
stronger and stronger not only the
French you know totally conscious of
themselves as a nation the English
similarly conscious over well sure can't
drag the law and some other people are
tracked along in the process but the
Germans in the previous century is you
know you have German states and you
still have this notion of the Holy Roman
Empire and electing people you know to
be in charge to be the Emperor but the
emperor is no power but by that point
and that's that's pretty much abolished
instead you have Austria you have
Bavaria and you have Prussia which is
going to end up dominating Germany as
sort of the big contenders for where
German leadership might come from and
there's this sense especially after the
French raise hell all across Europe that
well you might be better off if you
actually band together and have some
sort of cohesive governmental structure
so one of the key things that's half
in the 19th century is Germany finally
becoming no longer just a nation but a
state
similarly Italy is going through the
same sort of process in part because
they're unhappy but getting kicked
around by everybody else as well you
know when you look at the time line
they'll see things like Bulgaria
revolting Serbia revolting against the
Ottoman Empire any of these new
countries well not a tear
no new states definitely emerging man
each of which has their own ambitions in
the region and starts making alliances
so there's this great you know expansion
going on this nationalist impulse
there's also you know focus on national
liberation whether it's from the Turks
or the French or the yoke of the English
and their commerce or from the Russians
polish revolt against the Russians at
one point unfortunately getting crushed
in the process which would become a
dress rehearsal for crushing some of the
Russian knee lists a bit later and what
else is happening in this time
colonialism you know we we here were
originally a colony right England and so
colonialism have been going on for quite
some time but it really takes off in the
19th century
by the time that nature dies there's
only a little bit of the world that
hasn't been colonized by the European
powers you have Siam nowadays Thailand
as an independent country there's you
know little tribal areas here in there
where you know whatever colonial power
really hasn't taken over there's Liberia
begun by freed slaves who that
instituted their own sort of power
dynamics on the native population which
we're still seeing effects of in civil
wars today and then there was Ethiopia
almost every place else have been in
effect colonized I suppose you could say
Afghanistan as well because the Russians
tried their hand in
the British and neither of them really
succeeded in damaging to govern it but
for the most part the world gets divvied
up right and the old colonial powers
like Spain you know there's a revolt
very early on this continent well that's
to the continent of the South sorry
South America in this hemisphere against
the Spanish and all these new countries
emerge Brazil becomes independent of
Portugal during the Napoleonic times
Portugal really doesn't operate as much
of a colonial power so it's you know
Britain France the new Germany Italy
gets its little hand in start starts
trying to take over places everybody
wants colonies and the Russians are
playing around with things themselves
the Chinese are being divvied up between
the European and even American power so
you've got that going on there's some
significant wars that take place during
this century both in Europe and in the
rest of the world and there's massive
changes on the economic scene I mean if
you think about what things were like
just take any any area of life think
about warfare you know in the Napoleonic
Wars they were fighting most of the
casualties came from artillery in part
because you know artillery was so so
powerful and the muskets they were using
were pretty inaccurate by the time of
the American Civil War it's almost
completely reversed the rivalry has
become so accurate that that's where the
bulk of the actual
casualties are coming from of course
more people are still dying of disease
and the battlefield battlefield wounds
at that time but even that is changing
you know they're learning how to cut up
the body in efficient ways we're not
quite at the point of having antibiotics
but that is going to come fairly soon in
the next century technology economics
the development of the sciences all of
these are happening not only here in
America but even more in Europe
especially in Germany and France in
and Britain Russia is being affected by
it
Russia is kind of trying to figure out
who they are are they European are they
something different there's a lot of
people transfer you know anglicize or
german eyes russia involved their
infrastructure is spreading throughout
the land it's becoming possible to
travel quite easily so somebody like me
Chia will you know become a vagabond
later in part of the century and
communications a lot of the inventions
that I put on the culture timeline are
things like the transit the
transatlantic Telegraph cable is finally
laid you can talk between continents or
you know later on we have the Telegraph
they're not nothing does the Telegraph
the phonograph we have the telephone we
have all of these things being developed
there you know we talked about Lobos of
making us a smaller world that really
was happening at the time along with
this we have you know just amazing
developments happening in culture in the
arts you know think about the visual
arts not just you know the fact we then
got photography which is a big deal and
and towards the end of the century we've
been moving pictures but think about
painting and the fact that you know I
think you all know that story when the
the impressionist first exhibited people
were actually trying to strike at the
paintings with their canes we've got a
lot of the art museum and we look at
that stuff we're like yeah that's that's
pretty you know I like the way I like
what they did with the colors this was
revolutionary to people it was it was
changing the way that they they see
things music somebody who mean she was
going to become involved with is a major
innovator Richard Wagner is changing
music yeah literature philosophy all
these all these other fields culture is
is in the process of change and so some
of the people I want to mention I don't
think we'll stop for a little Q&A or
discussion
that are there involved and some
important developments in terms of the
culture that affected me chip in
particular would be Arthur Schopenhauer
Schopenhauer was a German philosopher
not all that well known in part because
he is kind of a jerk and he also tried
to square off against Hegel at a time
when Hegel was extraordinarily popular
but by Nietzsche's time people are
actually reading him and Nietzsche draws
quite a bit uh Schopenhauer if we had to
just pick like a one-line thumbnail
sketch he said that the world is
fundamentally irrational full of
suffering and that's what's most
fundamentally real is the will not the
intellect but the will and that drives
everything else and the will itself is
irrational but we can figure out how to
make our way in a world that's that's
almost entirely screwed up he said this
is the worst of all possible worlds in
response to Weidman saying this is the
best of all possible worlds sooner in
Kierkegaard another he's Danish he is
another person reacting against Hegel
and the Galleon ISM of his time
Kierkegaard and Nietzsche are often
brought together along with Fyodor
Dostoevsky as the fathers of
existentialist philosophy right now
there may be a context in which you've
heard all three of these brought
together Kierkegaard is a is a religious
thinker but also a very important
philosophical thinker and a social
critic who argues against some of the
tendencies that he sees in his day to
reduce the individual to just a part of
the system and Nietzsche is actually
going to find out about Kierkegaard
towards the end of his life through
through another Danish guy who will talk
about David's trumps anybody know why
he's important I've even heard of him
he's kind of old hat now that ring a
bell for anybody he wrote a critical
study of the Gospels so he's one of the
people applying what we call the
critical method to these religious texts
he's engaged in in the process of
reinterpreting Christian
and like many of the you know critics of
that time he's saying a lot of the stuff
that religious people believe in is just
mumbo-jumbo crazy stuff we strip away
what we can actually determine as
historically possible we get a very
different you know picture of things and
you know for his efforts of course he's
is you know sort of the bad boys of
Germany at the time and people hate him
for it but he has a very important
effect Karl Marx what do you think of
Marx in terms of that's that's one that
ironically that's a collaboration right
so although we think of it well that's
Marx's work this Marx and Engels
together
what else is Marx particularly and
that's a great work the Communist
Manifesto Spectre is haunting Europe I
mean that's a nice way to start we're
going to talk about that in a moment
what else does this Marx guy do he's
very good at political maneuvering you
know all the other communists wind up
being less important than him one reason
or another you know he writes a book
called capo where he tries to show how
economics really works as opposed to
what people you know a lot of very smart
people at the time are saying is going
on economically you know book that
important
Thomas Pinkett he wrote something like
that recently it's equally dense and
equally difficult to summarize but but
you know equally important you might say
and Marx is trying to show everybody
that economics is really driving you
know social forces that we don't really
understand are in charge and that we
might be able to tweak them and get them
to do the right things Richard Bachman
he's not a philosopher although he
thought I think he thought he was
and I think Nietzsche what's he known
for yeah what kind is it like soft and
sweet like Mozart opera
oh the bathroom yeah
yeah what else do you think it's lime
the wells what else sort of impresses me
if you have to like sum up vogner
besides atomic influences okay subject
matter
well the that's right he's taking and
this is Kenneth Hagin with the
nationalism of the time let's let's you
know revitalize German culture this way
you know he added extra thorns
particularly that on the low end to the
orchestra he made changes in how all the
orchestra was set up so that it would be
louder it would be more powerful he he
develops what I'm trying to remember the
German phrase I think it's gazhams the
quince quince bear meaning that told the
total artwork right it takes in
everything it's not just sound coming at
you like wall it's also these stories
that are also very you know growing and
lots of stuff going on and ideally
you're like totally surrounded by it so
he's rethinking how artwork functions
and how we might immerse people I mean
it some people vogner is actually sort
of a forerunner of things that were
still experimenting with today I have to
admit I'm really I don't get into vogner
myself my wife really does she really
loves his stuff but I can't have some of
the same reactions underscore yeah
Hitler in his plane flying through the
sky which she did yeah I mean it's a
wonderful piece they used it in
Apocalypse Now as well you know the air
camp coming in playing it out of these
loudspeakers to terrorize the people who
they're attacking you know there's
there's a lot of I think that's probably
one of the most adapted pieces right you
see it in comedies
tragedies and propaganda pieces yeah so
let's talk now about Nietzsche himself
and I gave you the timeline then it
really has three things in it Friedrich
Nietzsche other people and then sort of
general European culture and of course
an intranet summarize everything that
Iran said that it had been like a scroll
you have to unroll so you know I I
highlighted more like you know certain
certain interesting scientific
discoveries or technology or certain
political events but there's also you
can also see these other people like
David stress write writing the life of
Jacob Jesus alexis de tocqueville with
his democracy in America 1835 this is
ten years roughly before Nietzsche is
born so he's coming into a context in
which there's already a lot of political
ferment going that he's born in this
place rubican yeah he doesn't he doesn't
get to have a father very long as his
dad dies the official verdict is
softening of the brain nobody's quite
sure what that means but it's some sort
of mental disease yeah and his brother
dies his brother it was about two years
old he dies fairly soon after that as
well and the family relocates to Nam der
in another part of Germany they move in
with some relatives and Nietzsche you
know does pretty good is that a kid he
attends these he attends a gymnasium
give nausea but he's sort of like you
know I think of it as a college prep
sort of school you know like we have
some here in this area he starts writing
and he writes one of very early essays
by the time that he's 12 on the origin
of evil nobody really looks at that
stuff because you don't expect great
things 12 year old but he's writing and
he gets accepted into this foreigner
school which again
think again college prep a nice place to
be and he meets a Paul Dusen who he's
gonna become a friend writes a piece of
music
and eventually he's going to go to to
college and he starts studying philology
in Bonn he writes on moods and he's
going to leave bond which is a nice
place to study but this is the thing
that happens a lot of students you find
a professor who you really want to work
with in nature's case it's this guy
ritual philologist and philology at that
time you know it what we would call it
now as classics right officially it's
the sort of the study of my English yet
like theological philology which
teachers started out in and then you had
classical philology we were just leaders
call it classics and we don't have that
many departments unfortunately that
still do this and they're kind of
closing quite a few of them up in our
culture but it was understood as a
important part of Education and
Nietzsche's going to draw a lot of his
insights from his fellow logical studies
by studying language by by studying
literature you can learn Allah so he
goes to licensing and Saxon to continue
to study with ritual there you read
Schopenhauer and Schopenhauer has a very
important early effect on him in his
studies he does military service twice
first time he you know does military
service with an Artillery Regiment Horse
Artillery Regiment a Prussian one
because Prussian a sort of uniting
Germany and he manages to injure himself
screwing around a horse jumping on to
him he hits himself on the pommel and it
bruises his ribs if any of them had
bruised ribs worse than cracking a rib
hurts for a woman I know from experience
because I actually did it myself but it
wasn't jumping out of course it was
reaching for something in a car and
hitting myself on the wrong thing that I
had there and boy that hurt for like you
know three four months so I can just
imagine what what poor Anisha was going
through
because you know he was actually up for
rank in the military and it seemed to be
doing pretty good with that he meets and
befriends Richard Wagner starts writing
more stuff homer in the classical
philology and eventually he has
appointed a professor now notice where
is where is he getting appointed it's
not in Germany yeah Basel which is
actually in the french-speaking part of
Switzerland ball you know nice place to
be
I've been there most places it's was
actually pretty nice at present and he
becomes a university professors and I
always got kind of an established life
right and it becomes friends with
friends over back it's going to be
somebody else who writes to then he does
military service again as a hospital
attendant during the franco-prussian war
hospitals were not a good place to be as
they still pretty much heart today
they're they're a good place to get
healed they're also a great place to get
sick he gets sick he gets dysentery and
diphtheria probably lucky he didn't get
something worse some people think he may
have actually contracted syphilis there
there's a lot of theories about what
went wrong later in his life nobody is
really quite sure we don't have the
documentation for that and then he
writes this really important work his
first major work the birth of tragedy
that's actually called the birth of
tragedy out of the spirit of music and
it's a revolutionary reinterpretation of
what Greek tragedy was about with these
very major sort of big picture overtones
and vogner thinks it's great vogner
praises it to the skies the main guy who
really needed to impress at the time
I've got on here Ulrich von Villa
LeWitt's
Miller Middendorf says this is not a
good book and so that's a kind of low to
Nietzsche's prestige and it's career you
notice he's not going to write all that
much
till later up you become friends with
this guy Paul Ray who he'll mention in
some of his works later on he's going to
meet us loose Alamein through Paul ray
by 1876 he breaks with vogner he says
this guy's just a buffoon I was mistaken
about him he's not revolutionising
German music he's actually making it
worse you know he goes from one side to
the other and then he publishes another
major work human all too human this is a
really nice early work and it's it's not
systematic much of Nietzsche's
philosophy was actually rather
anti-systemic human all too human is
essays and aphorisms and you got to kind
of piece together what's what's going on
and he starts to experience of bad
health his migraines eyesight problems
he actually resigns from the university
and then he begins his his wandering
ears and he's going to do that more or
less the rest of his life until his
mental breakdown he only stays in each
place for a couple months and then moves
on somewhere else during some of this
time he's incredibly productive some of
the time he's totally incapacitated he's
actually writing his own prescriptions
and filling now because you could get
away with that back then signing the
doctor Nietzsche you know what kind of
doctor was he who's not a medical doctor
he was a doctor of philology but you
know that's the sort of thing that you
can do and he he starts having more and
more experiences connections he writes
you know the more Morgan Road to the
dawn sometimes you know it's translated
in other ways and then we get his
meeting with Lou Solomon who is with
Paul Rand Solomon is a very interesting
character in our own way
if any of you are
interest in Raider Maria Rilke the great
German language poet it's hard to say
exactly what nationality is such act we
could we could say although as part of
the Austrian Empire at the time he spent
time with her later on after actually
after in each of Dimes she became a
student of Freud and is one of the very
first female cyclists at this time she's
involved with ray and she also you know
has these these sort of dalliance is
with Nietzsche Nietzsche you know tries
to get something going with her never
succeeds again there's speculation that
maybe she gave him syphilis probably not
true at all you know there there's all
sorts of crazy stuff out there but it
doesn't work out and Nietzsche is very
active at this time he writes the gay
science he starts writing in 1883 the
spoke without soothe Zarathustra whereas
arethusa you know so aster is one of the
central characters got no connection
whatsoever with the actual historical
version you know founder of a religion--
but he's a very important sort of
character and that book actually gets
read quite a bit not only later on but
in nature's own time one of the the
tragedies of nature's life is that
people aren't really reading him all
that much until later on when he's
incapacitated by mental illness by 1886
he breaks with his publisher inst
Meixner
in part because he says this guy is
publishing all this anti-semitic stuff I
don't want my my stuff just getting
buried in this this crap I'm going to
start publishing it myself so in a way
if you think about you know we portray
Nietzsche's philosophy and we think
about philosophers as these you know
Kent's date academic types Nietzsche was
really more of an entrepreneur by this
point in his life he's traveling he's
financing his own travels
he is meeting people he's networking
he's self-publishing he's doing a lot of
really interesting stuff a lot of it
sort of a voice crying in the wilderness
at this point in time but that that's
happening you notice that he encounters
Dostoevsky
he reads Dostoevsky works and he says
this guy really I can see what's going
on here
he and I have some sort of connection
he's a great psychologist and then he
publishes what myself I actually
considers his greatest work which is the
genealogy of morals many many other
people I think would disagree with me
and say other texts by Nietzsche are
more important but I think that's
actually the best one and what I gave
you is my hand up here is something
connected with that I'll talk about that
but notice in 1888 this guy is just
churning out works you know the case of
Bognor twilight of the idols the
Antichrist at you homo nietzsche contra
vigor he begins a correspondence with
the scandinavian playwright lacustrine
berg and then soon after that in 1889 he
suffers a mental breakdown the story is
that that he's in turin and he sees a
horse being whipped which is kind of a
common thing at the time he goes puts
his arms around the horse to prevent it
from being whipped collapses they put
him in a hospital they realized that
there's something wrong with the guy and
he starts writing letters to his friends
signing them do missus you know somebody
who'd been important in his stories or
the stories of a suit of his philosophy
yeah his friends realized he is nuts
that by this point there's something
really wrong here so they managed to
bring him back to Ghana where he's
hospitalized by this by this time his
sister is starting to get into the
picture she had married you notice in
this thing she married this anti-semite
first and he and her attempted to found
a thing that they call new Germany and
Paraguay Paraguay was like one of the
places you could go
two crazy ideas back then you know you
could almost like set things up from the
ground up you get away with just about
anything and that's what they did when
he kills himself she moves back and she
sort of takes charge of me she takes
charge over his literary works
she starts forcing people out starts you
know saying this guy's not a good doctor
he's not handling the case and
eventually she has complete control over
his works he dies finally in 1900 right
at the turn of the century of pneumonia
and noticed that one of his great works
is published after he dies the will to
power these were a set of notes that
he'd been working on now the will to
power is gonna have a really interesting
history we now have you know sort of the
full thing but his sister Elizabeth who
was a raging anti-semite she puts the
the notes together in a form that's
going to sort of fit her mentality of
what he's supposed to be teaching this
is why Nietzsche was so easily co-opted
by the Nazis because of what his sister
had done meetcha actually was not a fan
of German nationalism he writes in very
derogatory terms about the Germans and
not only in the medieval times but in
the modern times he writes and similarly
skated in terms about anti-semites he
does of course attack Judaism does of
course attack Christianity but he thinks
the anti-semites are about as low as you
can get so what she's doing is is you
know really falsifying the picture of
his work I've talked now a lot and we
then we're about 40 minutes in we should
quasi suppose for some questions that
I'll tell you about meal ISM and how
beat you fits into that because that's
in the title we haven't gotten treaty
sense so any questions and comments er
issues objections to the way I've told
the story because goodness knows other
people could object you know any history
it sounds kind of selective
or should we just should we just go into
Neela's alright let's jump right into
the darkness
so this terminal is emit comes from the
Latin word nothing media right and if
you ask like 20 people who know anything
about Niall ISM what Neal ISM is today
you're probably gonna get 20 different
answers because it's taken out a lot of
different senses over time the original
use of that is actually within a
religious context this guy in okapi who
is you know in the sort of German well
it's called German idealist he's not
really an idealist but he fits into that
spectrum he's criticizing taunts and
chickens to German philosophers that
said that you know we in effect create
the reality that were seeing our minds
project order out to the world we don't
actually know what's out there in the
world independently of our minds and he
says this is menial ism it's going to
reduce us to not knowing anything
instead of this crazy stuff we should
rely on faith we should adopt what we
nowadays comfy day is we should we
should say faith will reveal everything
for us and you know the term has kind in
the currency Strauss I mentioned he gets
called a nihilist but nobody really
takes much notice of calling people that
at the time four-year by Ludwig
Feuerbach very important humanist he
gets called that machs Turner
egoist philosopher he gets called
immediate list and the idea is you call
somebody and needless to say if you go
down this path it's gonna lead to chaos
it's gonna lead to that nobody is going
to know anything nobody's gonna be able
to hold any moral truths to be
self-evident it's all gonna be like a
free-for-all you don't want to do that
right so don't go with those knee lists
then it becomes a popular term in Russia
when I said why why would it jump from
Germany to Russia well the Russians were
very
by German culture just as they were by
English and French culture and there's a
guy George Aeneas who has got a book I
don't know if any of you have read it
called fathers and sons beautiful story
that I like to Jeana I'm kind of fan and
there's a character in it whose name is
bizarre off the Zaroff calls himself
analyst and you know at first the other
characters like what is this and they're
trying to figure it out well it means
nothing so he must be for nothing and
and bizarre off explains that you know
they're there to change Russia but they
don't really believe in anything they or
they believe in whatever they want no
values are gonna hold them back and this
kind of gets the ball rolling
the meal lists become a force in Russia
and so you have this period from like
the 1860s
where if it's kind of a counterculture
within Russia it's scandalous and you
know if you're a conservative when you
find an a-list well you whip them that
well that'll take the idealism out of
them you know but the needle is there
for all sorts of things like free love
at least for some people or freeing the
serfs or you know doing this changing
things and they're questioning everybody
so in a way they're kind of more
skeptics and then straight out a list
then it takes a turn you get this guy on
a chaya writes this pamphlet the
Catechism of a revolutionist and this
argues that look the European monarchies
the power structure is using the ideas
of Machiavelli look at what Jesuits are
doing they use that they'll do anything
to achieve their ends there was a big
fear of Jesuits at the time it's got I
mean if you look at Jesuits today it's
kind of hard to square that with the
fears that people have now or back then
because they seem almost like powerless
now but there's a big fear of that and
so this guy was arguing if we want to
free the serfs or we won't have a better
society we have to do so by any means
necessary nothing should stand in our
there's nothing that we can't do and he
took me ilysm from being a kind of you
know almost like a party boy philosophy
right to being this hardcore austere we
are the wave of the future thing and
they start assassinating people and
eventually they manage to assassinate
the Czar as you can imagine there's crap
after that and a lot of the me lists are
wiped out you know to be a me list in
Russia after that is basically a death
sentence and so the word now has come to
mean something like a terrorist or you
know these people who don't believe that
anything Oscar Wilde actually writes a
play in which Emil list is a main
character and there's a lot of worries
about you know what's going on in in
Europe you know are the young people
getting into this sort of thing
Nietzsche yeah basically well there's a
lot of discussion about is Isis
basically nihilistic or did they believe
in something I mean it's interesting
because Isis you know from what we can
tell it seems pretty opportunistic a lot
of the people who got into it you you
know they'd ask them well what Quranic
verses have you actually memorized
oh I haven't memorized any I just want
to fight you know you're not really
doing the same thing that is like these
other movements so there's there's some
question about that there's there's a
lot of other movements that get give
them called me allistic in our own time
and so let's talk about Nietzsche that
so Nietzsche sees kneel ISM as sort of
the fundamental problem of the modern
human condition but he understands it in
a different way it's no longer just
about like individuals who say screw the
power structure we're gonna we're gonna
change things up cuz nothing really
matters instead he's thinking about the
entire culture and he says kneel ISM
occurs when the highest values devalue
themselves
so you mentioned the death of God right
Nietzsche is associated with saying
there's somebody in here
his debt okay okay so what does he mean
by that does he mean that there was
actually some you know cosmic God figure
through at one point maybe didn't get
fed or you know trip downstairs and he
died and now there's like a power vacuum
and maybe somebody could go ahead and
fill it no he means that whatever it is
that we consider to be the highest value
and in the Middle Ages this was God and
you know the enlightenment science
replaced that whatever it is that we put
at the top has shown us that it's not
really what we thought it was as
promises are false that our will to
truth leads us into more and more
tangles that it doesn't provide us with
happiness that it doesn't provide us
with this sort of everybody can get a
lot instead as an ancient sound to be
looking to the abyss and you know he's
got the famous line you look into the
desk the abyss also looks into you
people have been making jokes about that
recently you know you're looking to the
abyss the abyss looks into you and then
you realize that sorry the abyss was
actually looking at the guy behind you
you know but the idea is when we get
down to things
there isn't any true meaning in life
there's nothing guaranteed and our
culture presents us with all sorts of
you know things that says here's here's
where to identify your place you know
fit yourself into this hierarchy and you
will know where you you belong and wife
will make sense the death of God means
no that's vacant and everything else
starts to kind of crumble which means
that anybody can do just about anything
to anybody else and things start to get
very dicey because people need meaning
and they'll do just about anything to
get it now identify with some political
movement well identify with some some
new religious movement they'll turn to
crime and think that by doing that
they're gonna somehow change things so
Nietzsche is really concerned about this
he's not an a-list himself but he thinks
that we can't avoid
dealing with us and if you look at what
happens to European culture after
Nietzsche
you know things are looking pretty good
at them you got some political terrorism
and every once in a while there's a
revolts you know the workers and stuff
like that and you know there's some Wars
but in general aren't things getting
better and better and better in Europe
as we reach the turn of the century you
know medicine people are living longer
kind of unlocking the secrets of what's
in our our crazy heads you know
communications are proceeding you know
although the other people in the world
are under the European y'all can being
civilized by that you know we're getting
more and more civilized or something
look even the the dirty you know workers
and the masses we're civilizing them
then and then what happens to sort of
throw this real monkey wrench into it
after Nietzsche was died
what's the world war one yeah because
why would the most civilized countries
in the world go into a war with each
other over silly stuff you know the
assassination fascination of an Archduke
and some alliances kill off an entire
generation of young men in horrific
circumstances you know the people who
went through that they're like this is
all bs this is European culture you talk
about I don't know what your what you
mean what I know is the trenches and you
have a whole new generation of people
are being raised with that and seeing
that the great promises of what
Dostoevsky called the Crystal Palace
they don't come true and then soon after
that we have you know the we have of
course the Russian Revolution and we
have the Russian Civil War we have the
rise of the sort of radical right
fascism and Italy in other places as
well the Communists are a major threat
they really were indeed a major threat
so the Russians had the ambition of
turning everybody in Europe to the red
side we also see a worldwide oppression
you know things just go into chaos so
maybe there is something to this mail is
amiss you know we could call it cultural
rot the notion that the culture that
we've been sold doesn't really deliver
on its promises so then the question is
what do we do in that case do we say oh
screw it and everybody is a faker
everybody is full of it I may as well
just get mine yeah or I may as well try
to build the biggest empire I can or I
may as well just you know break the laws
and do do whatever I want or maybe even
I'll be the one enforcing the laws
that'll be better I'll be the cop and
then I can do whatever the hell I want
because nobody's even watching me
well I enforce the laws on everybody
else what do we do that Nietzsche
actually proposes something different
and this is where we get to this this
handout that I gave you which is very
complex right I don't expect you to like
you know look at it now there is no test
or anything like that but I'll give it
to a nutshell Nietzsche
thinks that this is one of his key ideas
niall ism is not something radically new
it's always been there lurking in the
background it's become pressing in our
time and one of the reasons it's become
pressing in our time is not just because
you know the death of God and the
highest value is devaluing themselves
it's because our are the ways in which
we value things are fundamentally
screwed up
he thinks that originally with warrior
cultures he thinks this is not just in
the West he talks about Japan as well
and an Arab culture originally the
valuation is good and bad this is why
one of those books is called Beyond Good
and Evil
there's no good and evil at the start
there's good and that's the class of a
powerful who call themselves good and
this happens in you know Latins this
happens with the Greeks this happens
with the arabs this happens with the
iranians they call themselves good and
then they tell the people who are below
them the servants the people who are a
lower class you're bad and by bad they
just mean you're not us
you're not the real people we're going
to boss you around and tell you what to
do if you don't like it rise up and then
maybe we'll take you seriously that's
when he calls master morality good
life-affirming bad just not up to snuff
and you know
Nietzsche thinks things go alright for a
while and then comes what he calls the
slave revolted morality everything gets
turned upside down and the bad the
people who are weak band together they
have some allies from from the masters
as well from what nature calls the
priests you know we're kind of renegades
and they manage to get in charge of the
culture and they manage to get in charge
of political institutions and they
economic institutions - they've managed
to start making money and they turn
things upside down and their way of
evaluating things there's secondary
evaluation is to call what we're
previously good evil was where the
distinction between good and evil comes
in the evil are the ones who are as
nature calls birds of prey right the
mean tough warrior class people who
would exploit you who if you cross if
you cross them they'll kill you
they are mean they are wicked they do
bad things they are predatory and those
of us who aren't like that because we're
not like that we're good notice is that
as opposed to saying listen I'm good and
if you want to be good you get in the
lists with me and fight but if not shut
up because you're man this is you know
affirming something of me and then
affirming of the other person in this
case it's denying something and then
denying something more
so it's reactive nature says and it
doesn't actually make these people happy
you know they have a sort of dominance
for a while so you know Nietzsche was a
you know big full of democracy socialism
anything that would put the the
oppressed classes up on top he was
against that but he wasn't against it
just because he was like screw poor
people you know there's dirty
or something like that he thought that
this actually subverts genuine morality
and we may not agree with that right I'm
not a Nietzschean in that respect
although I I certainly experimented with
it back when I was younger like I said
but this is what he thinks is going on
along with this is another process that
he calls Rose on tonight and he thinks
that our culture is just infected like
you know almost like with a virus Bob
rose on to them and what result amount
is is when somebody does something to
you and you want to respond aggressively
but you've got to choke it back you
can't do it maybe you know they would
get in get in the way of your prospects
or they would punish you or you know you
lose your livelihood or something like
that so you suck it up and you do it
better and you engage in some imaginary
revenge instead and eventually Nietzsche
says this kind of Fermat's into this
this whole thing that turns into a
complex where you're always sort of on
the lookout to seek some revenge
passive-aggressive people are like this
you would say and they're always looking
for targets and they love to tear things
down but yours were you know Nietzsche
is responsive they never put anything
new nothing positive in its place
Nietzsche thinks that our response to
mean ilysm in our present culture has to
be going back somehow to this master
morality to this you know affirmative
way of dealing with things
asserting oneself being okay with being
powerful being okay with other people
who are filled with Rosatom on telling
you that there's that their self and
ignoring them so that you can develop
fully as a person yeah are you saying
resentment
well that's pronounced resultant while
the French it's actually spelled a
little bit differently if you look at it
there isn't right and then there's
Rosanna months
I just wanted to make sure yes technical
term it sounds like you talk about
resentment so think about it as
resentment on steroids resentment that
has become a like a whole way of living
and the person themselves often they
tell themselves stories about how in a
potential they tell themselves they're
just seeking justice they're just doing
this they're they're really a nice guy
but yeah that's what Nietzsche thinks is
at the core of a lot of our current
institutions so you know like just to
take a silly example if nature were
around today he would eat an American
Idol
why the hell should we vote about who
sings well you know this is crazy
putting this to him folks
he'd also hit the top 40 you know when
it comes to music he probably wouldn't
like much of anything
quite quite frankly of what we do today
but he would be against it because it's
sort of just the masses running the show
you know and sometimes we have these
demagogues who you know are able to
mobilize the masses I would say nature
would look at both of our political
parties at present and say that they're
both mass parties they both represent
coalition's neither than Foster's
anything like genuine virtue genuine
human you know potential they're both
just sort of out for their own
constituencies and they both tell
stories about that he'd probably said
that about most the parties in Europe
too quite frankly as well it wasn't a
big party guy but he would be for the
people who are doing what when he
eventually is gonna call being the
Superman goober mensch
sometimes we call it the older man
earlier it is where he calls us the free
spirit now you might say well who the
hell is that okay looking around is are
the people who just like roll over
everybody else
the Superman it kind of depends are they
using the apparatus of the state to do
that are they using some backing from a
whole bunch of other people to do that
maybe they're actually just expressions
of you know this is heard morality
beaches maybe they're not really doing
something that's liberating but Neetu
thinks that this is the the proper
response to the crisis of meal ISM now
one thing to point out is this something
that most people could do no it's not
really an option available to most
people
so Nietzsche is only writing to a
selective group so I don't know that we
would actually want to take doesn't say
aha follow my solution to the problem of
cultural crisis or anything like that
Egypt probably isn't the guy to go to
but he does have some really interesting
diagnosis maybe what is rotten in our
culture in certain ways you don't have
to necessarily accept the whole story
that is teaching in order to get
something out of it I think so let's
pause for some questions at this point
Oh today I don't know there's always a
lot of discussion in sort of pop culture
once people start reading it you like is
this guy whoever matches this lady that
revenge I don't know I think I suspect
it in a lot of cases we wouldn't know
who they are because they're successful
in and doing things and not getting in
the public eye because of it I mean some
people might say big cultural figures
like say Beyonce but then you think well
what are they advocating a lot of the
time nature would look at that and say
no definitely not you know so they don't
work some people you know something that
we're saying Trump is a Nietzschean
figure I think nature would take a look
at Trump and be like that guy forget it
no way can't control his impulses you
know he's got a tweet all the time
definitely needs the approval of other
people I don't think he could be an
overmatch somebody doesn't expect or
didn't
Lance where it gets kind of interesting
so Nietzsche portrays the dimensions
being this very aggressive type right
the question is now why do we do good
deeds do we do good deeds because we
feel in the moral obligation to if
that's the case then whatever it is that
we have the moral obligation to ISM
certain times more powerful than us
right so the uber bench couldn't be
somebody doing that but if we imagine
somebody who just decides to do that
sort of thing and nobody else is going
to tell them what to do and it's sort of
an overflowing of their their capacities
in their being they're gonna make a
difference in the world they could be
able to match but then we wouldn't we
wouldn't really know about it you know
some other candidates like when we do we
want to save these captains of the
industry like Bill Gates or Steve Jobs
yeah I mean Steve Jobs is a jerk but I
don't think that being a jerk is about
that's right
or the Amazon guy pesos those would be I
guess three big ones with maybe uber
mention would be the plural through that
maybe I mean the other thing is to so
let's say they are like that what does
it mean for the rest of us you know do
we just like then find them and got a
hero worship them I don't lot of people
didn't Steve Jobs you know but it's not
I don't know that that helps us
yeah funny because they they still as
far as I know I don't think they've ever
shot a prophet and yet more and more
money and more and more of our like
economy in our world gets sucked into
Amazon just a couple days ago a whole
bunch of websites went down and people
are like what's going on at the internet
you know here
here's our entitlement mentality the
Internet should be there for me all the
time what the hell is happening here
right people even posted it you know
here's all the sites that are down well
they're all using Amazon Cloud storage
so there was something wrong with the
Amazon Cloud storage all those sites go
down that's how much about influence
they have you know but is it something
that would from a Nietzschean
perspective would be a good influence or
is it just spreading more of cultural
morass you might say that's hard to say
yeah he was a race car fanatic did
Sheldon that yeah yeah
was nominated for eight Oscars I think
finally one one for the that clearly a
master of his craft but when his son
committed suicide what did he do he
started Newman's Own okay all that all
the profit opposing to all the profits
go to charity
yeah so if he's not an uber mention in
in every aspect of his life the Annis
and his reaction is his commitment to
his marriage in every way he excelled he
was above you know I don't know I don't
know what Nietzsche would say but I mean
how can you well so it's like something
is part of it and then it's you can
think of motivation are you doing it
because you choose it as the values for
yourself yeah or are you doing it
because somebody else is telling you you
need to behave like that
you like that because you're satisfying
some you know mom and dad in the back I
think maybe I think you're right
Newman could be a really interesting
example of somebody it's harder to know
about him like he chose this stuff he
said this is the way I wanna live my
life he didn't have to do that and I
don't think there was anybody
he wasn't doing it just like you know
avoid paying taxes why are you giving
all of your profits away yeah I'm rich
man I don't anymore for ya
rather than trying to maximize it and
you know make it even more yeah I mean
with the wind with with gates in how he
divested himself and created a
foundation his wife fit into that I
don't know a lot of it would depend on
the motivation I don't I don't know
enough about their motivations I'm not I
don't study captains of industry very
much okay I know that they do help me
help me see to restore eyesight in India
they all support my well is a I searched
in India one of the top ones and that
organization is there simply to
basically do cataract surgery and just
restore sight to I think they just only
do cataract surgery vast amounts
millions you know the Gates Foundation
gives the all sorts of stuff you know
National Public Radio's supported by
them they they do bring the the recent
educational thing that everybody had to
get behind for a while what was it
called a lot of people got very angry
but both on the lofty right that was
that was a gates initiative you know the
question would be what kind of what kind
of values precisely
is he being motivated by and what you
know what is sort of the effect is it a
good thing to remove people's cataracts
I mean I think you and I would say yes
Nietzsche you know insofar as its
enhancing life I guess you'd probably
say yes if it comes to be seen as
something that's like old maybe you'd
say that's that's more the same this
might be where we differ from each other
yeah just because we study somebody
doesn't mean that's agree with I did
also want to talk about Nietzsche's
influence
later culture as you know I mentioned
that things really went to pop you know
not too long after himself died if you
look at the wars that were going on and
some of the skirmishes you can see that
their trouble was brewing before 1914
but then after you know 1918 things
really were a mess
Nietzsche by the end time had come to
exercise quite an influence on European
and even American culture and by some
Nietzsche gets called me enlist ik you
know he's not actually for me and he
sees it as a problem he's got sort of
response to it but he was a people
started reading the birth of tragedy the
spoke zarathustra the will to power and
and really he gained a great cultural
currency this notion of like the
self-made person some people took that
in the notion of cultural decadence and
that's somehow we have to revolt against
it some people use Nietzsche to argue
for fascism as a matter of fact when the
German soldiers went off to fight many
of them went off with each of their
rucksacks now it was okay
sanitized Nietzsche way of understanding
things the sister had helped out with
quite a bit because if they'd actually
read all of nature they'd have been like
well he thought anti-semites were
terrible German nationalism isn't a
great thing either so maybe we don't
want to take him along but he had a very
big cultural affect the influence writer
after writer after writer actor writer
and what's really interesting is that
each of them seem to take different
things from him it's not as if there's
one totally agreed-upon interpretation
of Nietzsche there's all these different
Nietzsche's Thomas Mont if some stuff
Martin Heidegger took other stuff gets
younger took other stuff they influence
each other
but you know they they differ as well
and it's still going on today he still
plays an important role within not just
philosophy literary studies
understanding history
media theory I mentioned people ask the
question is Trump and Nietzsche and
finger they can ask that because
Nietzsche is still culturally relevant
today or you know as Isis nihilistic
they look to Nietzsche as one of the
people who tells us what nihilism is so
he still has a major role and I think
you know
could you have handed Nietzsche say two
centuries before him probably not
Nietzsche thought that me ilysm was
really great to be the problem of our
time he says in the world of power what
I relate is the history of the next two
centuries
so the century that we we've seen end
and the century that we're living in
today I describe what is coming what can
no longer come differently the advent of
nihilism for some time now our whole
European cultures been moving as towards
a catastrophe with a tortured tension
that is growing from decade to decade
relentlessly violently headlong like a
river that wants to reach the end that
no longer reflects that is afraid to
reflect so if you thought that realism
was going to be the fundamental problem
I mean we might say other than the
environment right clearly we're in kind
of a pickle when it comes to that we can
couldn't produce a coherent politics of
thought what we have to do in terms of
massive influence that we've had on the
environment over the last couple
centuries and what we might do to keep
you know safe Great Lakes from not being
here right I mean that rising to the
level where we'd have to worry about it
here we might say that other things are
bigger issues but nature thought that
Niall ism in a certain sense was at the
core of all the problems that were can
encounter that's kind of a big thing to
say
kind of curious what do you think about
that idea but somehow that cultural
malaise would be at the core of all of
my problems rather than other things
that we might have identified like it
quality environmental issues right you
know so what you're saying is oh yeah
yeah he's not neol ism was the
fundamental problem yeah yeah I think he
to make their equity he's right yeah I
think the biggy saw himself as like
somebody who could see what was going on
at the time and other people were like
in denial about it and it became harder
and harder to be in denial I mean I
think he would look at the present he'd
say well most people still don't get it
yeah but still our fundamental problem
was the profit yeah I guess we could say
if you would as a profit do I mean
traditionally they they speak for God I
guess you could say Nietzsche's trying
to speak for she was a social problem
yeah I mean any frames himself is like
the herald of the Superman and he wasn't
the Superman of song I mean he was
pretty sickly us to emulate that a lot
saying yeah
well I mentioned this to you when I
first got here did you read the book
man's search for meaning
Branka yeah now here's something about
Nietzsche which actually I didn't know
before when Viktor Frankl was in force a
concentration camp and then a deaf camp
in Auschwitz mm-hmm he found that the
people who survived because he always
the people who survived were the ones
who had a reason yes survive I mean she
said he who has a why to live for can
bear almost anyhow right yeah and he
found out that he wanted to live
cuz he wanted to see his wife again she
died all and his parents died everybody
died yeah but it didn't matter whether
they wanted to wait there why was a
noble why I want to see my parents again
I want to go to Israel or I want to kill
as many Nazis as I can't even matter
they had a way to live for and they
endured they or the how and I think I
didn't know anything about Nietzsche in
Delton item and and what I read in
Victor Frankel's book but it seems to me
that you can pick your way doesn't
matter what UI is you can bear almost
any how if you have a wife yeah I think
Nietzsche would say if you pick the
wrong way and you really invest yourself
in it and then you realize that that's
false you're kind of screwed but it can
pick the why and you pick it just as
it's gonna be your life right you say
yeah like for example Nietzsche you know
thought religion was pretty much you
know just nonsense certain social
purpose that purpose is lost and served
you know all this stuff that religious
people talk about none of it's true
but could you like say yeah I can't get
that I still like going to church still
still get something out participating
I'm gonna choose it for me knowing that
it's it's all you know nonsense but it's
my nonsense I think nature could
actually say okay you go ahead yeah you
do that and that would get you through
your way you're talking about you know I
mean it's still better if you can
believe whatever it is that you're
you're having as your Y but yeah but
some wise just wouldn't work anymore
I mean it's interesting because the
people that he criticizes the most are
not the religious people they're the
people of science who think that science
like solves everything for us Nietzsche
would be looking at the Hawking's
and neil degrasse tyson's of our time
and saying these guys don't have
do it great doing the little thing
physics
you know cosmology or astronomy but when
it comes to actually like thinking about
life they'd open with the helmet ocular
they think that philosophers death they
they're like way out of their element
and they only they only do that because
they're basically the substitutes for
what priests used to be back in the day
and the people who like buy into the you
know if'n long science sort of mean
stuff he would say yeah they're they're
totally deluding themselves what science
reveals to us is a cosmos that is not
only without meaning but crazy that
doesn't seem to make sense in a lot of
cases it doesn't reveal to us this you
know nice pure vision that we get in our
chemistry textbooks or or things like
that this is what Nietzsche says and
he's saying this back in the 1800s so
you know India is kind of a prophet for
criticizing that sort of stuff yeah I
think you know he may have the diagnosis
right but the solution is
yeah so limited you know I guess you
have to sort of come you know istic I
think that's the cure for most of us
it's not going to happen
yeah I think that that's a legitimate
criticism that maybe we're like we want
to accept part of the diagnosis and say
okay that he's useful for this but this
this uber bench thing I don't know if I
want to get behind that or not you know
good yeah most people yeah
great quite true yeah I mean if I'm not
doing them eventually probably beat me
up and take my stuff so I don't think I
want a lot of other matches around make
me work for whatever I'm not an uber
mentioned
well any any other questions or he is
comments I don't have any other things
prepared afternoon thank you very much
okay
[Music]
you